Hey, what's going on? It's bill burn. It's
the Monday morning podcast from Monday,
July 22nd,
2013 off we go into the wild blue yonder.
Ah, fuck. I gave a bunch of shit
to do today. People just like you.
Even my Mondays are busy. I actually got
a lot of shit out of the way already.
I walk my dog around the block.
It took a shit.
I picked it up in a bag.
All right,
I like that Rappaport fella.
I picked it up right and I put it in
somebody's barrel. Somebody else's barrel,
which is the right thing
slash douchey thing to do.
The ultimate neighborly thing is you
pick it up and you hold on to a t,
get back to your own trashcan and then
you put it in there. That right there.
That is a class act. All right.
Then you have tier two you have me,
well at least he picked it up, but then
the con threw it in my trash barrel.
I can argue, well, hey,
you know, to trash barrel,
what are you worried that it's just going
to smell like rotting garbage is the
shit smell really going to ruin it?
But I understand as a principal
it's your dog, it's your shit. Um,
you know, and you have the last one
is that people just don't pick it up.
But anyways,
anyways,
people have been breaking into cars and
my neighborhood, man, it's fucking him.
Every once in a while like this,
they'll come by here for a while,
then they leave.
La is really a weird city where it's like
you live in a place in one night it's
safe and then the next night it isn't.
You know,
there's the general vibe and then
there's also like the fucking rule,
that aspect of living in Los Angeles.
So I think they come by,
they fuck with cars because it's the
same people, right? It's five of them,
five people running the world and there's
five people breaking all the windows
and stealing shit in this
car. I'm convinced of it.
All right. I have, I have,
I have information that can back that
up. If you want it, I'll give it to you.
But I would appreciate it if you've
been listening to my podcast long enough
that you would just take me at my own
with my word actually means something to
you, you know? Um, anyways,
I've been breaking in these fucking
cars and uh, uh, it's just annoying.
I told you they had me last time. They
fucking, there was nothing in my car.
And then they took all my
quarters as little Satchel,
a quarters for the parking meters because
I still don't want to use my credit
card because I don't want to tell
people where the fuck I am. You know?
Well, she, according to your, your, you're
a fucking parking meter records. You,
you were there sir.
And I know what right now do it.
They can just track you with
your cell phone Yan. Um,
maybe they can.
Hmm.
But I could say, well, I lost my cell
phone. Someone else had it right.
I could come around with it,
but if he fucking down can say,
somebody stole my credit card.
I Dunno.
I don't like people watching me
all the fucking time. You know,
you know what kills me is the amount
of people that actually are happy.
Snowden did what he did
and there's nobody any,
anywhere in media with any sort of a
fucking job that pays any decent amount of
money that is open in their fucking miles.
Everybody's keeping quiet.
Yeah.
Good for you. Snow. Keep running. You
could stay at my house if you want to
hang out until you know, blows
over, you know, sit around,
eat some TV. Hey, you know what
I did this week, everybody?
I uh, I went out and I bought the,
the body issue, the naked issue.
The nude issue of ESPN. Why?
Cause I'm a pervert. Yes. Why?
Because I always liked the 40 niners
but wanted to see their quarterback
completely naked in the, on some
lava rocks. Absolutely. You got me?
Okay.
I can't remember how many times last year
when I was watching a 49 nighters gain.
You know, this call of Kaepernick, I'll
tell you, he's entertaining to watch,
but you know,
it'd be more entertaining if somehow
he would get down on all fours on some
fucking lava rocks. Like he's going to,
uh, do a hundred yard dash into the ocean.
That's what I would really like.
No.
You know why I bought it because somebody
told me Gary player was on the cover.
That's what I was told.
Am I Gary Player?
Isn't that guy like fucking a hundred
years old. They're like, no, he's like 77,
you know,
and I go, he's an unbelievable
shape. You know me,
I'm obsessed with not becoming a fat fuck.
Right.
Fat People call that having a body issue,
you know,
cause they didn't want to stop eating the
jelly and Ritz crackers late at night,
you know,
that they stuffed into ice cream.
You know what's funny is as mean as I am
to fat people, I've slowly begun to win
according to this guy last week.
And I'll take Kim is,
is like every fat person
who listens to this.
I'm beginning to shame
people into losing weight.
And I think that that
would be a great show.
It would be just like biggest loser
as far as the amount of yelling,
but it wouldn't be as motivational.
Oh, it'd be like the opposite.
And then it would cause a controversy
and then there would be people doing that
split screen on TV.
You know,
you got the host and then he got the two
people like, uh, you know, what, what,
what do you think a person I've never
heard of before or I think it's great.
You know, I think these fat,
Fuck Charlotte's both types.
Nobody called him a fat fuck.
What do you think about a female person
who of course you have to have the
motherly side of this?
Well,
I just think that people have to
understand that it's a food addiction.
This negative reinforced is we're
seeing this in schools with by,
Oh fuck you lady. Okay. I think you'd go
out with a couple of pounds still. Hey,
let's try to keep it
nice. So I, let's try it.
Like the fucking house who's exploring
the whole problem can then sit there
rubbing his chin, shaking his head.
You know? I mean, you know, it's funny.
All three of them in that moment,
they're all getting paid.
They're all making money off of the Lard
that's in the ashes of so many people
these days. And I, I like to think that
that's the true Tao a tragedy. You know,
I like to think right now that I'm
thinking outside the box, the ice box,
I guess. I guess you would
call it. What's the deal? Um,
so I got the body issue and uh,
you know what bugged me?
It w this fucking trend,
like the fucking tattoos
mmm.
That people have in order. It is in
particular, what is it in particular bill?
I don't like people who write
fucking inspirational shit on them
body, like, you know,
and they always have it in a
place, you know, they don't always,
but for a lot of times they have it in
a fucking place where only I can really
get a good look at it. So there's no
way for me not to take that is like,
what do you think I'm a fucking moron?
Like you have life all figured out
that,
you know,
you gotta write this shit on your body,
where the hell is it?
What the hell is this fucking
person who was this fucking Golfer?
Beautiful woman, right in like
a 1950s kind of way. You know,
little houses,
then they're all made out of Ticky tacky
and we fucked missionary only to have
more kids.
They have blue eyes,
they have brown eyes and they
all say fucking racist shit.
But it's the 1950s and
nobody knows better. Sorry.
Um,
okay.
That's a waterfowl niche just for us.
It's the 19 fucking fifties.
So this woman,
that's some of the worst second I've ever
done wolf that even sound that bad to
me. So this is fucking lady,
her name is Carly booth.
Gorgeous little diesel.
She sitting there on the driving range,
looks like in Manhattan
driving some golf balls.
I'm sure people going by and they're
fucking yachts, you know, all upset going,
is that naked woman playing golf?
And I wasn't invited to that party.
I don't have enough money. I thought
I knew Bloomberg too. So anyways,
she has written on the side of
her body. All right. It's a,
starts at her waist and then
goes down to whatever that,
that piece of meat is that's between,
uh,
it's at the same level as your ass cheek.
You side beside of your hip,
I guess you'd call it, right? Is
that what it's called? In the, uh,
the medical field. So anyways, it's
beautiful. Woman has something,
I can't even read the first.
It looks like the symbol for Pi.
I don't know what it is she has
written on the side of her body.
It says whatever is not,
yeah.
Oh, Jesus Christ. I can't read this.
Whatever is not the stars
to hold our destinies,
but in ourselves or a destiny. I
can't read it. It's too far away,
but I just don't know why. Why
do, why do people do that? Yeah.
Is that for when she's hooking
up with some guy, right.
And he's banging her doggy style and
he kind of leans over and he looks,
and then he reads that and like, what's
he supposed to take that right? Like damn,
it's bitches deep.
Wow.
Okay.
They're endless guys.
Get them to, you know,
try to be a little fair,
a little more fair and balanced and
the spirit of Fox News here, right?
Totally lean one way. But I tried to just
say I'm fair and balanced. This. Let's,
let's, let's search this
right now. Shall We? Um,
tattoo sayings. All right, click on there.
We got some images here.
All right. Oh well,
look at all these beautiful
girls with sentences. It's like,
not only do you get to enjoy that beauty,
they get to help you out with life.
Let's see what we got here.
Let's view all images. Well,
make them bigger. You can't,
all right. This gorgeous woman,
she's doing that thing where she puts
her thumb in her fucking a belt loop and
Polzer Jane's down a little bit.
That's like the classic when
you have like the bathing suit.
Okay.
A edition of sports illustrated.
He always got to have like for you
future women out there or male models,
I think guys can get away with it to
what you do is you're totally naked.
You have little speedos on and
you're not showing enough skins.
So then you got to take a thumb.
You stick it in the side of it and you
pull it down a little bit and then you
have this look on your face.
Like why sell thing happened.
Um, all right. She has on her side,
fall down seven times.
Stand up eight.
If you're truly a strong person, can
you know, can't you just hear that?
Just like remember it.
I am enough the way I am.
This woman has this written on her a
collarbone and it goes right into the, uh,
the ball and socket joint day,
whatever the fuck you call it,
a vol joint there and your shoulder.
I am enough the way I am,
you know,
like I see that all I want to do.
Yeah.
It's just give her a hug. Pat Her on
the head and just be like, I'm sorry.
Your parents did whatever they did to you.
I'm sorry.
They didn't say the things they
needed to say. Um, all right.
What does this person have? No,
it's written in French. You, no,
it's pretentious.
MMM.
In finite. I don't know why
you would have that on there.
Yeah.
This is my favorite one.
This guy has this written on his wrist.
Take a chance.
They don't come much bigger than this,
you know?
So whatever the situation is,
be it he meets the girl of his dreams or
some hooker who doesn't have a condom.
He looks down at his wrist and
that's what it says, right?
Okay.
I Dunno. It was just bombing. I was in
heaven. I was in hell believe in neither,
but fear them as well.
Damn.
Where are you really in
heaven and where you went?
Hell here on earth or did
you visit another land?
Okay,
it's fucking jerk off.
You probably unloads trucks.
He had it written on the back of his calf.
Right? You're just a fucking asshole.
You know you should've said asshole and
then a fucking Arrow pointed right up.
You fucking asshole. You know? Oh,
you pretentious conch with your fucking
song lyrics and crap on your body.
Can you put them in a place
where we don't have to look? Oh,
I don't have to look at, I'm going to
get to speak for everybody. All right.
That guy. If I was a
dictator, I was running shit.
All right.
After I assassinated or imprisoned or
pistol whipped every fucking bank or I
could find, I would
then be like, all right,
you have two options.
You either get that fucking thing removed,
all right?
Or you never wear shorts again.
You're allowed to wear your underwears
when you walk around your apartment,
but that's it. Other than
that, go fuck yourself.
Look at these fucking people.
Every new beginning comes from
some other beginnings and,
oh Geez. Wow, wow. I never
looked at it that way.
Thank God you wrote that on your rib cage.
Would you like another fuzzy navel?
Oh my God, this girl's got an
entire story but not a back.
Okay.
I just love this passage and I always
wanted to have it written on my back.
All right, the shoulder blade
tattoo. What does she got here?
What does this one say?
That was a lot of women with the shit
written on their backs and different
languages. All right, here's to me,
here's to you and here's
to life and laughter.
I'll be true as long as you and not
a single moment after Jesus Christ.
Yeah.
What in in it literally looks like she
wrote it on her back and had someone else
fill it, fill it in. He
used to me, here's, yeah.
Okay.
Love never fails.
All right.
This guy's getting written on
both forearms. I listened to the,
I listened to the Bray of
my heart. I am. I am. I am.
Oh my God, Dude. These are like, you know,
the thing I like about this shit that
they write it on their bodies is,
that's just a great thing to read during
your, during a first date. All right?
Here's the one for you. If you, if
you meet a girl with a foot tattoos,
like you got to go in another direction,
right?
There's nothing uglier than a foot
tattoo. They just did. You just,
I don't understand. I don't
understand. You know what?
I'm sure there's a lot of you guys out
to probably most of you at this point
have tattoos,
right?
You know,
at what point are those things
going to go out of style?
Okay?
Has this podcast just completely lost
momentum? I feel like Lenny Bruce,
when he fucking just kept
reading his, uh, his court cases,
I really got way to enter that tattoo. I
just fuck it. I'm not enough. I am enough.
Every fucking athlete,
that's stupid issues.
Got some big dumb ass piece on
their back and their shoulders.
And you know what I
gotta be honest with you.
It all looks the same bunch of squiggly
squibs scrabbly dues is always a or a
fucking dragon in there.
You know,
the fuck is wrong with you.
Everybody else has what?
I want one too.
It's one of the greatest things I ever
did was I never got a fucking tattoo it
back. You know, it's funny,
back when, uh, when I was,
when I was just the lad
and he got tattoos people,
it was the tail end of getting like
cartoon characters like just about four
inches away from your Dick.
You know, we get it like you,
I remember there was a
guy had you sent him, he,
Sam with the two guns and said back
off and it was just to the right of his
package. You know, I knew another guy,
he got the fucking Budweiser label.
That's what you got.
You know,
he didn't sit there and
have to be like fucking
okay.
You know,
a stitch in time saves the sorcerer
who gets up early and catches the worm.
Yeah. A bunch of fucking constant. You
know what, keep getting your tattoos.
I like it.
You know,
it's branding you as someone
not worthy of talking to um,
give you guys do that for me this weekend.
Can you walk around when you see people
who have those and when you just read
them, just point at them like
you're in that version of the body.
Snatcher and just go,
oh
yeah.
Damn.
And then fucking walk away. No,
don't do that. Don't you know what?
Don't even listen to me. Um, all right,
the fuck was I going to talk about this?
Like, oh, guess what I did this week. Oh,
freckle face bill. Guess
what I did, you know,
a year ago I wrote a fucking motorcycle
or whatever. I went dirt bike riding.
I actually took a motorcycle
safety course. It was a,
it was a day and a half
and I got to tell you, man,
it was fucking a exhilarating
and terrifying. So I actually,
I passed the class somehow.
I don't think I should have,
I was doing my little youth turns.
They had to put my little foot down there.
Uh,
um, no, it was a great fucking time sell.
Basically how it worked was you rode for
like four hours and then he had a class.
MMM.
I realized how spoiled I am as a fucking
human being, you know, just having this,
the life that I have where I don't have
boss and I basically do whatever the
fuck I want.
I have not been in a classroom.
MMM.
I just immediately,
I just takes me back to why
I chose the route I chose.
I just never liked the classroom
situation, but this, this was a,
was actually a great time,
but it just immediately had anxiety and
I'm like half paying attention and then,
and then in the end they're like,
okay, now we're going to do the test.
I went right back to when I was
like in eighth grade. And I got got,
I'm going to fail this. And the guy's
like, no one has ever failed this.
And you're like, oh, good
pressure pressure. I'm a moron.
Was sitting at the table and everybody's
fucking finishing. Before I was like,
there was like, I don't
know, 40 people in the class.
I think I finished 37th as far
as completing the test. Um,
I don't know. It's 50 questions I got
for run. It's like something like that.
How fucking though?
But somehow I passed and um,
okay.
That was funny. I've never flipped
flopped so much of my life on a decision.
I was thinking, am I going to get a
bike? Should I just get a dirt bike?
Should I just know how to
do this? And then, you know,
yeah.
I just wanted to learn how
to ride a motorcycle. You
know, I grew up in the 80s.
All right.
I watched a lot of action movies and one
of the things that I always was envious
of the Action Heroes Aside from their
oiled up fucking eighties lifting weights,
no squats ever bodies,
was
uh,
the fact that no matter what
vehicle they approached,
not only with the keys always in it,
they knew how to drive it.
They knew how to drive everything from
a dump truck to a fucking helicopter
airplane. They could sail, they could
fucking do anything. So, you know,
it's coming up where, you know, we
got to raise the debt ceiling again.
Eventually the wave's going to hit the
beach and there's going to be a period
where you could quite possibly be getting
chased down the street by an angry we
fucking mob is, is this,
everything goes to shit, you know?
So at that point it would be
nice if you had the ability to,
whatever escape vehicle
you meet you ran into,
you could actually just jump in and
just be all right with it. Right.
Sylvester Stallone, fucking, uh,
Arnold Schwartzenegger,
Steven Seagal, Chuck Norris.
They never it,
I challenge you to find anything that
they fucking ran up to when any of those
movies that day did not a
jet ski fucking motor boat,
sailboat,
submarine,
combine helicopter fucking plane with,
with only can land on water.
Those skis or the tires
doesn't make a difference.
They could instrument
rated they everything.
Yeah.
Everything. They could be on a
fucking plane, a commercial airline,
and somehow kill the person next to him,
put a hat over their face
without anybody noticing,
crawl down where the luggages and then
jump off the landing gear and do a
fucking mash at the end of
the, the, the, the runway.
They were unstoppable.
So I've added motorcycle.
All right.
I could drive a car stick or regular
and now I can drive a motorcycle.
I'm just checking off the list.
I have a day and a half of experience.
No,
it's actually really fascinating and it
made me a better driver and I actually
have a much more appreciation of,
uh,
okay.
Of this skill it takes to ride a
motorcycle. It's not like a car. Yeah,
no shit bill now,
but just shit that you wouldn't think.
Okay.
Like I didn't,
I didn't understand all that went into
just going around a turn on a motorcycle
and out. Not only do you hit the, do not
hit the break, but if you hit the brake,
you're actually gonna you know
you're going to crash.
You gotta judge to look
through the whole turn,
judge you speed and then fucking
power your way through it. Um,
pretty good tense. I got not going to lie
to you. I'm not gonna act like I was, eh,
got this.
This is easy that we were going into
the class and like has anybody seen it?
And I'm getting excited like wow.
Then I just wrote a bike for four hours.
I've got it up to third gear
down and this is fucking great.
And then I went into the class
and one of the things, you know,
the group discussion there was like
anybody ever see a motorcycle accident or
been in a motorcycle accident?
It's like fucking almost everybody,
or at least half the class puts their
hands up and they start telling stories in
this one guys was like a paramedic
and he's going like, Yay. You know,
I saw this guy was going like 90,
he hit a car head on and his
heart came out of his chest.
He had like all these stories and
I was sitting there, I'm like,
okay,
like laughing at myself going,
what the fuck am I signing up for here?
This is insane.
Um,
okay.
And then like the guy who was teaching
the class who looked like he was born on
a motorcycle and was fucking, you know,
wrote the same way it was. You know,
obviously he's the instructor,
he's fucking great. Ryan bikes.
He even had a story of a couple
months ago. Yeah. You know,
I hit some sand and I was like singing,
oh,
I'm going over the fucking handle
bars and I'm like, keep my body relax.
And all I'm thinking in my head is just
like, dude, you went down, you went down.
Yeah.
Right. This guy, I'm telling you,
it just looked like he was
just made the ride a fucking,
we just had that I ride a motorcycle look,
as opposed to me who looks like some do.
She goes to take a safety course and
I'm just thinking this guy went down,
this guy's an EMT talking about people's
hearts coming out of their chest.
I'm just like, what?
This is fucking stupid.
Okay.
You know? So, uh,
okay
on, I don't know where I'm at. I
think I'm just going to maybe just
right on dark is what I'll do.
You can't,
you can't fuck or ride a bike out
here in la. You know what it is?
I'm old enough to know it's fucking
stupid. So, uh, I think I'm going to,
if I'm going to do it,
I just get like a dirt bike and
I put it in the back of my truck,
drive out of the city and
all the people texting,
get to where the trailers and
then just ride around on dirt.
And I know all you constantly be like,
yeah,
actually [inaudible] PTLD Jap in
off road people, not PA. Could you,
I know I just stand this
risk with everything, but uh,
you know, I dunno. I,
I think it's a good thing that I waited
till I was 45 to learn how to ride a
motorcycle because if I was thinking
if I was 21 and I would just,
I wouldn't give a shit ass.
I can happen to me.
And that's not going to happen to me.
Like you get older and by the time you're,
my age, shit has happened to you or some
close friends. So you kind of like, yeah.
You know,
that could happen to me.
Kind of like my heart in my chest
on this side of my rib cage. Uh,
but I got to tell you though,
I definitely got the bug and
okay.
It's the most fucking fun.
Okay.
I even by the second day I was actually
getting frustrated because I was
thinking like, I just want to
take this out on the street.
I'm sick of speeding up and slowing down.
I just want to drive this fucking thing.
And uh,
okay.
I Dunno. Don't worry. I'm not
going to go out and do that.
I'm not gonna do that dumb shit.
This is exactly what a lot
of people do when they,
when they finally get to
where they want to be in life,
which is what I feel I am, you know,
selling the tickets as a comic,
get some acting gigs every
once in a while. You know,
you got a little free time.
What do you do?
You pull a John Denver,
you go out and get a pilot's license yet
out you fly some experimental aircraft
and next thing you know they're
the news today. Singer songwriter.
All right. So that's definitely
in the back of my head. But um,
yeah,
I dunno, I don't think nick is
going to let me get one anyways,
to be honest with you.
That's probably a good thing.
But you know what she did
when she was saying no,
she did the classic thing like
why do you want to like, you know,
have all these toys. What is it with
guys and have, you know, you have your,
and like, what do I have? I
go, I get my truck. She goes,
you get your guitars and it's like, you're
upset with me cause I'm a joint life.
And she's like, no, you know, I think
she just doesn't want me to get one.
So she tried to do that stupid argument
that the motorcycle was this extension.
Like it's like you, Dick, like you,
you guys like it's between their legs
and they have ride this thing down the
street. It's just like, I dunno
what the fuck that is about.
Okay.
When I was riding for the last two days,
at no point was I thinking about
my dick other than thinking like,
I hope I don't fall off and,
uh,
when I'm going fast enough
that I get road rash on my leg,
Dick,
that would be the only thing. Other
than that, you know what, I wish,
I wish she took the class with me.
You know?
That's what I was actually think it'd
be great if she took the fucking class
with me and she would just see
how much fun it is. It's fun.
Okay.
You know, I don't know. Fuck it.
No. So, uh, I got the bug now.
I The bug and I was looking at motorcycles
all last night, so I was telling her,
I said, look, all I want to do, I'm
just going to get like the Honda rebel.
It's a fucking two 50. It's exactly
what I should get when I start out.
If I get something else up, kill
myself. And she starts, you know,
looking up those stupid Ducati's, which
were cool about up until six months ago.
And now every Douche
bag out there has him.
Like everybody seems to have
one of those fucking things. So,
you know,
I don't know.
And I looked at the new Harley's and I
don't like them. I think they're ugly.
They kind of lost their way. They lose
used to look meaner. So I'm just going to,
if I'm going to get one,
I'm either going to get dark bike or I'm
going to get this little fucking two 50.
I think the speedometer only
goes up to like 70 or 80.
MMM.
I Dunno. Tell me, what do you, what
do you guys think? And this is,
and this is going to be
one of those extreme,
uh,
conversations. And believe me, I've
heard all the things get a motorcycle,
you might as well buy the coffin
to go with it. It's not a helmet,
it's a brain bucket.
I've heard all of that shit.
Um,
I dunno.
Just dot.
It does seem like a lot of fun.
Right.
You know, if I, if I get one,
I'm going to be one of those douchebags
who gets like a little two 50 and I'll
have like all the gear on and
be dressed like all Samuelson.
If he ever rode a motorcycle,
flipped completely over,
protected fucking Robo cop suit on it
and I just ride around my neighborhood,
never, never get out of
second gear. Um, anyway,
so that's what the fuck I did
with my week. But, you know,
it's good to know though,
if I ever get chased by a bunch of people
with hatchets down the street and I
happened upon a fucking motorcycle and
there's a little key there provided it's
not an old one with the throttles on the
other side or the shift or whatever the
fuck it is. Uh, I'll be able to,
I'll be able to escape, you know?
Okay.
All right. I know what the fuck
I'm talking about. Okay, everybody,
it's time for a little bit of advertising.
I know this is your favorite part
of the week. Well, God damn it.
It's mine to Bill's finally going to
stop babbling and actually read something
that's prepared. All right, here we go.
Uh,
okay. He voice everyone.
You're screening calls,
closing deals and making money all while
lounging poolside in the summer sun.
Thanks to who he voice eve voice is a
better way to connect with people that
drive your business. He voice will
forward business calls to your home,
mobile or any number you choose.
Wherever you are, he voice.
We'll find you don't
have time to take a call.
It's routed to voicemail and you can
read it at your convenience as a text
message. He voice not only gives
you an edge over your competitors,
it takes away the edge of the big
companies have over you right now with he
voice. You can create the appearance of
a whole office building of departments.
When customers call you a
sales department, customer
support, tech support,
you name it.
It's going to sound like you have it all
through the wonder of the voice and it
works with any phone, even
yourself. Hey, it's summer.
Don't be stuff stuck
in the office all day.
Free yourself with a 30 day trial of ee
voice so you can see what I'm talking
about over here.
Go to [inaudible] dot com and enter the
Promo code bill for your 30 day free
trial. That's [inaudible]
dot com promo code bill,
or go to the podcast page on billboard.com
and click on the voice banner.
And uh, the next one, Tivo, Tivo.
Tim Tivo before Tivo
watching TV was weirdly hard.
You could only watch a show at a certain
time and if you missed it or even part
of it, you literally had to wait for it
to go into reruns before you could see it
again. I could vouch for
that. I am an old man.
Tivo totally changed all of that.
And while other dvrs exist,
they are not as sick. Alicia says
Tivo because if you have cable,
Tivo lets you watch your shows
wherever you want. With Tivo stream.
You can watch it on your iPad all
over your house and even transfer your
favorite recordings and take them with
you on an airplane waiting in line at the
DMV, the dentist office, Ti votes,
it makes other dvrs looked like they were
designed by some Soviet con committee.
Only Tivo searches both cable and
web to find any movie, any show,
any video at the press of the button,
you hear that both cable and the web.
That's what sets him apart.
Netflix, Netflix, Amazon,
Youtube. Uh, now those are just
like more channels on your TV.
Oh Wow. You can look at all
of that. That's amazing.
And what the Tivo mini one Tivo box works
on a second TV from the couch to the
kitchen from the minivan to
35,000 feet up in an airplane.
Tivo makes TV about a
thousand. Time's better. Um,
there you go. Alrighty. Thank
Bang. That was easy, wasn't it?
All right, let's get
back to this. So anyway,
so I'm looking at the body issue here
and uh, I'm telling you to get inspired.
Gary player. The guy is like 77 years
old. I forget what he's it, five,
seven ways of buck 55. He's like it
his high school way. There he is.
Here he is who he is.
Golfer Pga tour winner
achievement award winner.
He's five, seven 150 pounds. Um,
I got to read this quote that he didn't
have to have tattooed on his tattoo
lists body here. You said a great
man in India said to me, Mr. Player,
the less you eat,
the longer you live in western society,
it's each eat plenty and die young.
I'm 70% vegetarian this morning.
I didn't have any fats. No
Bacon, no sausage, no butter.
But I'm a normal human being.
I have a snickers if I want one.
I'm not a martyr now my duty, you can't
if that's not something too buyer to,
you know,
last time I was at one 50,
I was in fucking,
I mean I'm taller than the guy,
but what was the guys at his
high school weight? You know,
you can still fit into his fucking
Tuxedo that he wore back in. Uh,
when he danced the Benny Goodman, you
know, you know what's funny about that?
Vegetarian Shit. You always
fight it, right? You sit there,
you got to have some meat. You
got to Blahblahblahblahblah.
But I got to tell you,
do you need a giant salad? Every day
you're going to be right as rain.
You can eat a steak and afterwards you
can feel like you have a fucking shoe and
your stomach, you got
to take a nap. You know,
your body shuts down if you have red
meat and potatoes, right? You know,
God damn well, you got to take a nap. You
literally have to fucking sleep it off.
You know, you never have to
sleep off the salad people. Uh,
that's what I've learned as I've gotten
older too. I got to stop fighting it.
You know, I want the meat eaters
to be right. Does that make sense?
Okay.
Who wants to eat a fucking stunt?
You want cheeseburgers and fries to be
the right way to go? Of course you do.
But I'm telling you, uh, oh, did I mention
I finally ate a tomato out of my garden,
my little modest garden.
Dude, I got to tell you,
it was one of the most fucking
unbelievable experiences of my life.
It was, it was like, I don't,
I don't know what the fuck I was eating
for the first 45 years of my life.
Um, I've got to tell you,
don't do it if you want. Don't,
this is great. I got tomatoes growing
right out in front of my house,
cucumbers and peppers.
I'm on my way.
I'm gonna have a bunch of fucking
veggies growing out there.
I know how to ride a motorcycle, right?
So I'll just have a bag of veggies.
Always ready to go. That's, that's my, uh,
that's my game plan.
But the other thing is,
is if anybody on my block knows my
game plan, if they listened to this,
then I'll let it going to do. It
was just still my vegetables. Right.
And puts some piano wire across the
street and that's going to be the enemy,
you know?
Okay.
Wouldn't that make sense? Oh, here you go.
I just got a text message
answering a question.
I would have this tattooed on my body.
Hang on a second.
I've been playing a lot of drums lately,
everybody and I've been fucking with that
Zeppelin Song in my time at dying and
I never know how to count it to count
it in for that Barbara Barrett do you
don't, when he starts off, when
the fucking drums come in, I never,
I I can't fucking do, I knew, I kind
of thought it was maybe in four, four.
So I got the answer here
to all you dramas out here.
This is coming from a professional
drummer. It's in four four.
If you mean the big Tom hits,
which I do, they are one
what?
They are one and have one and have to
get the fuck. So it's one end. And is it,
I thought it was convinced the guitar
riff that opens the song starts off on the
end of four.
Ah,
that's what it is and one and
two and three. Okay. Ah, okay.
You motherfuckers see that's the thing I
loved about Zeppelin is they always did
that little tricky shit.
Okay.
So that Dan, Anna, Anna, it
starts on the and to four and
then know. Okay. All right.
Was that the most boring thing ever to
hear me trying to figure that shit out?
MMM.
All right. What the hell was I
talking about? Oh, hey, I owe,
I owe a major fucking apology last week.
You know,
I have the apologies every week.
So last week I was talking about,
uh,
I got to get his fucking name here.
The Guy who won Wimbledon,
let me, let me look this here. When
we'll do the 2013 something Marie, right?
What's his name? He, Andy
Murray. And I said, hey,
for the first time ever, congratulations.
The first time ever an English guy,
when the fuck in, uh, the Wimbledon,
turns out the guy was Scottish.
So right there I gave Andy Murray
is props and instead of calling,
but then I called them English,
which is a classic example of what
that is.
Some cold lotion.
I wanna hear somebody sent me some audio
that with the fucking Scottish accent,
I apologize to everybody in Scotland.
People of Scotland can't stand
English people, you know. Actually,
most people in Ireland can't
stand him either. They're not,
they're not a very well
liked group of people.
And you know why people just hating
on him, you know, just hating on him.
I'll fucking successful.
They are with their kingdom,
right? Great Britain, the English Empire,
the guy, you know, something, they are
like a franchise that got bought out.
You know, like, remember back in the day,
there was Kinko's everywhere you went.
You know what?
Oh wait,
blockbuster feel like the blockbuster
video of fucking empires actually,
every empire is after a while.
You just get bought out by something else.
And I would say that, uh, our empire,
the United States were like
blockbuster in like 2006. You know,
you see the writing on the wall.
Um, so that's it right there.
You can't be a tub of shit. It's
coming to an end here. People.
Something's going to fucking happen.
All right?
So you got to get your ass in shape.
You've got to start growing tomatoes and
he got to learn how to drive, ride sale,
any fucking thing that's out there.
Um,
okay.
Uh, I'm a fucking moron. I don't have
anything to talk about this week. People,
I'm not going to lie to you.
I got nothing. Okay. Usually
I talk about sports. This,
oh, I know what I can talk about in
the wonderful wide world of sports.
Did anybody see Nellie going
off on Coby or discussing Coby?
Huh? That's why I finally, I feel
vindicated. Somebody else's seeing it.
He's talking about dove white.
Howard, Doug White. Howard leaving,
going. Maybe he doesn't want to play
with Colby. And you know, it's so funny,
Steven A. Smith is sitting
there going, blasphemy.
Blasphemy as as he's as Nelly is credit
has the audacity to criticize Coby
Brian. That's why I love Stephen A.
Smith cause that's the funniest thing.
And he's saying blasphemy like Nellie
is talking about the son of God.
That's how blinded Stephen A.
Smith is about criticizing Koby Bryant
because of his friendship with that guy
and protecting his
interview. Stephen A. Smith.
I know you can't say it.
Come on. Come on man.
You know, you know the deal.
Koby Bryant, they're the,
in the history of NBA basketball.
There's never been another
guy who's gotten more help
getting five championships
that Coby Bryan.
All right.
The same way the Celtics piled on in 2008
and the Miami Heat the last couple of
years. Koby Bryant every year
he's on a team like that.
And I'm talking to my buddy Jason
Lawhead this say and Lebron.
The rumor is he's going to opt out.
So as Carmelo Anthony and
they're both going to go to la,
how much more fucking
help does this guy need?
Unfucking believable, but like Steven A.
Smith, can you ever address this? If you,
somehow somebody sends this to you
because I am a huge fan. All right.
Explain this to me at the risk of you
saying blast for me as I say this,
how a player like Coby Bryant can walk
off the court twice this year during
horrific losses,
walk off on his own team.
You tell me how that does not breed
resentment in the locker room. All right?
And how doing shit like that all year
does not end up with your fucking star
center saying, I'm leaving. All right.
And I'm not saying that, you know,
Mr. Howard didn't fucking fall short.
All right. I just hate saying delight.
It's Dwight Dwight Howard,
Doh white. Spell it.
D U H white. All right. Um,
I dunno.
All Dwight Howard has dudes just steal
a couple of moves from a keen and a
couple moves from Kevin Mchale and
he's going to be fucking unstoppable.
And he had a look on his face,
like maybe he was going to commit to
doing that for at least four days before.
He's going to have that silly grin.
Look how pretty I am and
look how big my arms are.
I don't give a shit anymore that
he brings to the court every night.
Do you realize if you include Steven A.
Smith that I just criticized
about 40 foot of a human being?
You understand that that could all kick
my ass. I don't know about Steven A.
Smith. I think I could take them to the
ground, choke them out with his tie.
Who knows? Blasphemy, blasphemy. But uh,
that's one of the youtube videos
of the week. You got to see that.
And then I also have a great, uh, I was
watching the NHL network this weekend.
A NHL network underrated. They,
they just, you know what they did?
They just, Oh, you know,
they just showed every islanders
clinching game during their,
their four year dynasty that
they had from 80 to 83. And, uh,
I got this great clip after the boot.
Who did they beat?
They beat the north stars I think in 1980.
Uh,
when Nystrom had that overtime goal,
fucking unbelievable pass to.
And uh, one of the Sutter
brothers had just been called up
from the minus and they interview
them and it's just like,
it's just what's the most unsafe,
smooth ending to an interview. It's a,
the name of the youtube videos is good
luck. We'll have that up there for you to,
uh, and with that, I've, I
babbled enough here. Let me, uh,
let me read a little fucking ad here and
then we'll get into the questions for
the week. Sound good? Well,
you don't have a choice cause that's
how it was going down. All right.
Do all a shave club everybody.
All right.
This is why I like dollar Shave Club
because for years I've been complaining
about why do they treat like disposable
razor blades like the gold bullions.
You know? For some reason
it's like 40 bucks for a pack.
They got up behind glass.
You got to find somebody with the key.
You know the the reason why
you know why people steal them,
it's because they're
horrifically overpriced.
Wouldn't it be nice if someone was doing
something about that while I give you
dollar shave club? All
right. Dollar Shave Club.
It's a cool brand and they send you
these quality radio written radios,
razors right to your door every month.
You don't have to think about it.
You don't have to wait in
line, get someone to unlock
the key. Then from the cage,
like I was just saying,
and pay way too much money for a bunch
of features that don't even fit on your
old handle. Shaving has become such a
mess, but not with dollar shave club.
You know what,
I'm part of this now.
It saves me time and it saves me
money and the razors are great.
They're just as good as any of that
crap behind the glass, you know,
except you don't have to go out
and get it. If you want to try it,
go to dollar shave club.com forward
slash burr support the show.
Got a dollar shave club.com forward
slash [inaudible] or click on the dollar
shave shave banner on the podcast page
at [inaudible] dot com once a month,
they're going to bring you your blades.
You don't even have to think about it.
You throw out the old ones.
Did He have a nice smooth shave all month?
You don't pay too much for
it. Give it a shot. All right.
God bless you and God bless the
United States of America. Okay,
let's get to the questions for this week.
If I could find them.
Oh Christ, what did I do now? What did
I do? Oh, it was great. I was talking,
I wasn't stuttering this week.
I've been reading copy, you know,
I feel like Mike, my copyright has
been good this week. All right. Okay.
Water a day.
Bill.
This is in reference to your podcast
and the consumption of water.
I fell off working. I fell off
working out when I was working out.
What, what do you guys do this
to me? I fell off working out,
but when I was working out regularly,
I easy was drinking a gallon and a
half of water a day, sometimes two,
two gallons. Someone questioned,
questioned me on this,
so I started to do research and basically
that's nowhere close to the limit.
Humans can consump I've consume
I think 10 liters a day safely.
Is that what you think, dude? You can
die drinking too much water like people,
please don't go out and drink two
gallons straight. All right. Uh,
he says thanks for the
three comedy by the,
that's what the reverse of Colt Lotion.
Thanks for, for the free comedy.
By the way.
What's the reverse of cold lotion like
when you get a podcast out late Monday or
Tuesday?
Yeah,
we didn't get the podcasts on Monday
because what Tuesdays mornings we're going
to have one.
Um,
you guys would just never get beyond the
fact that the Monday morning podcast.
It's my Monday morning. It's 9:44 AM
Monday morning. I'm recording this. Okay.
All right. I'm just like you guys. I see
it in my world. It's my Monday morning,
not yours. Go fuck yourselves. Um,
you know what's funny is this guy sitting
there like thrown out stats here and
then in the end he goes,
um, humans can consume like,
I think 10 liters a day safely.
So anybody listening to this don't
drink like I think 10 liters a day.
Find out how many he can have an over
what amount of, of what period. You know,
look, you can have 30 drinks in a month,
but if you drink them right in a row,
you know,
I don't think that's a good fucking thing.
So there's gotta be a way
to s to space it out. Right.
And a fucking though.
All right. All right.
The truth behind Jimmy's last week I
was talking about Jimmy's and I heard it
was racist. The reason why, you know,
so you call them sprinkles or something
like up in Boston at the reason why they
call them jimmies. That was a
reference to Jim Crow. A look,
got a couple of Jimmy's over the air.
And then a lot of the sprinkles
being chocolate and color,
it didn't translate it over. And this guy
saying that I am wrong. All Right, Bill,
love your podcast and it's great to
see you are getting more and more
recognition.
I'm from Massachusetts and heard your
comment on the podcast about Jimmy's
possibly originating as a racist term.
This is a bogus Smith and the history
of Jimmy's is innocent and actually
philanthropy pep thick. I can never
say that word. It's a philanthropist.
And whenever I see it, I can't
say it philanthropic, I dunno.
Fill anthropic fill
anthropic philanthropic.
Um,
so please don't get sucked into these
urban myths just because you heard it from
some idiot cunt.
Um,
seems that I've heard you blast
these types in your acts anyways.
Thought you would find this
interesting and go fuck yourself.
The Jimmy story is below.
There is nothing racial about the name.
Jimmy's and there are no connection
whatsoever with the Jim crow laws.
Jim Crow laws were anti African laws that
many southern states passed following
the civil war and they had
nothing whatsoever to do
with maths at Massachusetts.
Now, wasn't Jim. Jim Crow was,
was basically separate but equal and
it was never equal. It was separate.
Shittier, but called equal. Correct.
Is that what it is? Anyways,
um,
here's the story.
The bring of family of Boston was in
the restaurant business in the early 19
hundreds of 1911 based on a
bequest, a bequest, not a real,
not a request of request
from the patriarch.
The Peter Brendt Brigham
Hospital was founded.
It later merged with the Boston lying
in hospital and is now known as the
Brigham Women's Hospital. Three years
later in 1914 a son Edward l bring them,
started the ice cream restaurant
in Newton called Brigham's.
I remember that place.
Brigham's was the shit.
It later became a chain of restaurants
in 1927 Sidney Farber graduate.
Jesus Christ is going to be this long.
Can I just tap out and say, you're right.
1927 Sidney Farber graduated from
Harvard Medical School and became a
okay,
a pathologist.
Okay.
At Peter Bent Brigham hospital cheese.
It's too fucking long.
In 1929 he became a resident just at
the children's hospital. Meanwhile,
1930 a candy can't fade out of
Bethlehem, Pennsylvania. Do it.
Can you just get to the fucking point?
Bethlehem Pennsylvania called just born
introduced chocolate grains that could
be used as a dessert topping.
The man who ran the machine that
made the grain was Jimmy Bartholomew.
So the grains did.
Grains became known as Jimmy's,
you know,
everything was sounded great.
You had all these dates and all these
long names of hospitals and they like,
yeah, with some guy named Jimmy
and he came up with them. Uh,
fast forward to 1947,
Dr Farber established the Children's
cancer foundation known as the Dana Farber
Cancer Institute.
The next year in 1948,
Dr Farber established a fund
raise money for children's cancer.
A 12 year old boy named in our Gustafason.
This is such bullshit at this point.
These names are too long. Became
the poster boy. He attracted wides,
assists the Jimmy Fund.
MMM.
We attracted widespread attention after
1948 radio broadcast for the purpose
keeping the boys and MIT.
It was agreed that the poster boy should
have a more all American sounding name.
Yeah. Cause no one will care
about an ENR Gustafason.
Okay.
In our Gustafason once
you'll have your papers,
Peter Bent Brigham Hospital where Dr Fiber
First participated, supported the fun,
bring them restaurants.
Also decided to help raise money for the
institute by offering to put chocolate
grains on top of ice cream cones
and Sundaes for an extra penny.
They got the grains from
the Jess born company,
which sold them as Jimmy's the penny
went into the fund. When you got Jimmy's,
the boys nickname became Jimmy and the
fund became known as the Jimmy Fund.
Jimmy was a big fan of the
Boston Braves baseball team.
Today they are the Atlanta Braves.
Holy Shit.
Now we've got the history of baseball.
When the braise moved from Boston in 1953
the red sox took over as the sponsors
to the Jimmy Fund. That's how the
sprinkles became known as Jimmy's. Well,
you know what sir? Like
if that is an all true,
that is the greatest filibustering
ever. All right, well fuck it.
I'll call them jimmies
again because you said so.
Another unknown client who has a bunch
of dates with hospitals and all of that
and now know the rest of the story.
Jesus fucking Christ was that long.
You know,
it's funny you heard all of it now
it would be great to see if he could,
how much you could actually
remember and repeat. Hey Bill,
how did the name Jimmy's come along?
Ah,
there was a guy who liked ice crave
and he knew someone at a hospital.
Then a guy named Gustafason got
sick and then there was a gym.
He showed up with the ice creams and uh,
they would call Jeremy's,
there you go. That's, that
sounds how it came about.
Public service announcement for
divorce listeners. Hey Bill,
a couple of weeks ago,
you advise to force guys to go to
another city to increase their chances of
getting laid by a good 40%.
Did I say that? You know,
I'm just trying to fill an hour.
I don't even remember saying that
and now that I've read it back,
it doesn't even make sense to
me. Um, I concur. Oh, okay.
I guess it does make sense.
Allow me to provide a public service to
these guys and save them the trouble of
trying to figure out where to
go get to Amsterdam. Gentlemen.
I moved here four years ago from
Canada and it's been insane.
There are a couple of reasons for this.
None of which has to do
with weed or hookers though.
You can go that route if
you want. Reasons. Dutch
women, gorgeous with bodies,
sculpted by a lifetime of dairy
products and riding a bike, uh,
as a definite bonus.
Uh,
they are bored to death of
Dutch guys who have zero game.
It's like negative game. They're
all 14 year olds. No sense of humor,
no manners, no flirting skills, Nada.
Wait a minute. The whole country,
there's not one guy who's
fudge just slaying it.
There's always one guy in every
grade is a handful, but then there's,
that was the chosen one that
just has that thing anyways,
whatever. And he goes, as a foreigner,
you're way ahead of these stiffs as
soon as you step off the plane. Yeah,
that's true. Because you have the
accent. You're from somewhere different.
Tell me about Winnipeg. Um, and
it's not just the Dutch chicks.
The city is filled with hot
European women either on a,
on a weekend bender as a highly
impressionable intern because their own
country's economy is even in a shittier
place or as an expatriate sewing their
oats. It's a freaking gold
mine. Uh, you can get here,
you can get by here easily on English.
Everyone speaks it really well.
Throwing a couple of Dutch words,
Shit that you can learn on the plane,
and you've upped your chances by
another 30% anyway, they have at boys.
Uh, go fuck yourself. Oh, it says go
frig yourself. Canadian politeness.
Yeah. You know, that's something I wish
I knew back when I was a single man.
Just get your ass to a different
country and your intro intro instantly.
You're interesting. You
have an accent, you,
your clothes are a little different
at different perspective. You know,
you've seen that these fucking cops
come over from England MLL love.
Oh God,
I love your art.
This sitting there with
their fucking tight pants,
you could see their ankles in their
balls all at the same time. You know?
I'm all right for the birds.
Hey Bill,
I got these two parakeets.
My problem is that these
little dudes don't like me. Uh,
I've tried whistling petting them.
I don't know.
You can pet a bird and
squirting them with water.
Uh, do they like water? I'm
guessing that that's a good thing.
Parakeets like water.
I don't know.
Why don't we ask the fucking Jimmy's
guy to write a fucking nine pages on it?
I love all them upset with that guy
cause he actually did the research as
opposed to me who were like, oh yeah,
I overheard this in a bar. So anyways,
this guy's petting his birds.
He's fucking get them with the
water hose is Westlawn Adam.
Woo.
Yeah.
I'm all to no avail.
I know they're only birds,
but I feel they hold a
deep resentment towards me.
Where your clip their wings
and you stuck them in a cage.
How would you feel somebody cut
your fucking nuts off, came by,
started whistling at you
and throwing water at you.
You know,
I got an idea. Why don't you leave
him alone? She opened the cage.
Right?
Why don't you take him to one of those
car Dashi and doctors and I get a little
botox in their fucking
wings and let them fly away.
Okay.
Would that be annoying to you?
If you are in a cage,
your arms cut off at the fucking elbows
and somebody came up and running and
then whistle and they
started speaking English.
How are you speaking English at you?
He goes,
I think it's because I yelled at
them. Oh, here we go. He goes,
I think they were sent me
because I yelled at them.
Yeah.
What did you, what, what, what were
they doing? Uh, I said no with my,
during my shows,
uh,
basically I had to scold them
for pooping in their water dish,
but I had their best interest in mind.
Okay.
Do you understand how fucking insane you
are that you feel like you can talk to
a bird?
You know,
why don't you like not stick
the water dish, you know,
underwear that,
that was it underneath the swing.
Or what I would do is I just get a
bigger cage. I get a bigger fucking cage.
I put the water in the center that
isn't near any of those trapeze bars and
hopefully they won't be at the top
of the cage is still shit down on it.
Or I would accept the
fact that it's a burden,
a cage and that it's,
you know,
okay.
Basically anything at the bottom of
the cage might as well be the city of
Dresden.
Right.
I would just take that as part of it.
I wouldn't yell at the birds,
but it was this guy, he had to scold
them for pooping in their water,
but I had their best interest in mind.
I heard if they drink contaminated water,
it can cause a disease that makes
all their feathers fall off.
While you could also read up on it as
opposed to me who just repeat shits that
they, here he goes, I do a
lot for those little guys.
But putting jackets on nude parakeets
isn't one of them. Even if I wanted to,
I couldn't, they don't even let me
pet them, let alone dress them. Dude,
you're not a bird guy. You
should've got a dog. Uh, he goes,
when I originally bought them,
I imagine I would have one pair
of keyed on each shoulder. Why?
Hanging out around my house. But
instead, whenever I approached the case,
they freeze and horror every time
they do that, I can't help her.
Remember my brother's face when he fell
through the ice. We had to pull him out.
I thought maybe if I bought
them more toys, they would,
that would somehow help to birds.
Motivation isn't more toys.
Their motivation is you not having energy.
Like,
I'm going to fucking twist your head off
to their wings are clips so they can't
escape. You got him stuck in a cage
that terrified and you yelled at him.
I would say more than on one
occasion you yelled at them.
All right.
Um,
you need to fucking relax.
All right,
listen to this.
Would you,
would you want to be like your
job to be in a cage all day?
You know,
and then some,
you know,
I dunno.
Some giant comes home and puts
you on his fucking shoulders
and your whole job is to enhance the
giants fucking life. You know what?
I'm having a little bit of
empathy for the fucking birds.
What I would do is I would just have a
totally relaxed energy and hope that they
forget that you're screamed at them,
treat them nicely.
Don't try to pet them, just don't fuck
with them. Every time you come over,
they'll graduate and be like, Oh, this is
the guy who feeds us. Scale brings water.
This guys on our side,
you know,
as opposed to the mixed messages
that you send to them. Um,
yeah.
Birch don't give a fuck about toys.
You know,
do they? I don't think they do a, he said,
I bought them a new toy every Friday
on my way home from work and this is a
ridiculous amount of toys in the cage.
And here's the kicker.
They haven't played with the single one.
Not once.
What do do you look at the birds outside?
Okay.
They're, they're not out there. If
you leave your toddler's toys outside,
they don't go,
oh good.
They left and then they go down and they
start playing on his fucking tricycle.
He goes,
they just stare at me.
Okay.
I took them to the vet,
but he spent more time looking at
his phone and the birds. Anyways.
Any advice would be greatly appreciated.
Um, I think you should find a bird lover,
sir.
Okay.
And now give the birds away
and then,
um,
I dunno,
I think you should get your temper in
check and before and before you do that
yet, get your temper in check.
And then if you want to get a dog,
it seems like you want more
interaction with the pet.
Most people get birds because they can
have an interaction with an animal,
but they don't have to walk it down
the street. And uh, this is very,
a lot less interaction with them.
You seem like you want a bird to
like a dog slash a little kid.
Like, Hey, daddy's home. I
bought you a fire engine. Oh boy.
Look at that as a bell work. You know,
somehow you want the bird to do that.
Um, yeah, please stop
yelling at your birds.
All right. They can't help if they
shit in the water. You know, the birds,
they're not supposed to be in cages. They
fly around. And they shit as they fly.
They shit when they're on branches,
when they have to go, they go,
they don't have any stress,
they don't have any shame and
there's water all over the place.
So then I got them in this fucking
cage with little confined area water.
You know what are, what are
they supposed to do? Well,
what do I know about the restaurant
business? All right, size issues.
Oh Jesus. Here we go again. Here we
go again. Maybe you need a motorcycle.
All right.
Sizing issue,
a Cape Pasta Bill and Nardo Oh
la bill or not. They'll get past
show.
Uh,
we all know your disability
to read pop properly.
Well, you know what? You don't even
have to write a sentence properly.
Half of this shit is I get too far in
front of myself and the other half,
you guys don't have to
write a fucking sentence.
We all know your disability
to read properly.
Is that even written correctly
or am I a moron? Again,
we all know you have a disability
when it comes to reading properly.
Isn't that how it's supposed to be?
So when I don't have to fuck,
so I'm going to give it my best
shot to keep it very short. Okay.
You come in with the arrogance like you
have all light life figured out, right,
and you've got something
tattooed on your rib cage. Um,
as you may have read the
subject title of this email,
you may already know where
this is heading. Yeah.
You seem pretty cocky for a guy
with a little dick. He says,
I recently got into an argument
with my girlfriend who I've,
who've I've been with for a little
more than two and a half years,
where she told me that she
wished I had a bigger deck.
Oh Man. Ah, yeah. That
relationship is over, dude.
DEB relationship is over at
one or two ways. Either one,
she's just trying to be so fucking
mean to you that you break up with her
because she doesn't want to be the
bad guy or she's just such a fucking
self-involved human being that she
doesn't realize like how mean that is.
That'd be like he said, yeah, I like
you. I wish the tits were bigger.
That would just be the
mean is fucking thing.
Why would you say that to
somebody that you cared about?
That's a horrible thing to
say, sir. You know what?
You started off as an arrogant cunt.
Now I'm feeling bad for you, dude.
That's not the mother.
Your kids
just take the dick out of the equation.
Why don't you just said your nose is
too big? That's just fucking a, that's,
that's, that's, that's just a
terrible person says she goes,
I was shocked to hear this and didn't
know what to say. There's nothing to say.
There's nothing you can do about it.
This is the first time she
ever mentioned my penis size.
Also the first time in my life.
By the way,
I guess anybody's ever
brought it up to be honest.
I don't know that I'm not well
endowed with my 5.5 inch rocket.
You're a little below average, sir. I'm
not going to lie to you now being me.
You know, you can grab the rim, but you
can't stuff at home. You know what I mean?
Um, and I did have little, uh,
have insecurities about it in the past,
but learn to accept it and moved on.
I never heard any of my former bed
partner girls complain and the sex was
usually great.
Um,
I know that it may sound ridiculous,
but those few words were heartbreaking
to hear it put a big giant stain on my
confidence. Yeah. It's a
terrible thing that she said.
I haven't felt like having sex ever since.
And she made oh,
was ever since she made that remark.
And I am afraid it's going to be awhile.
I haven't spoken to her since
the arguments since I work a lot.
We don't live together. I
know it's a stupid thing to
be upset about. No, it isn't,
sir. You're a 100% and the right hundred
percent in the right. And he goes,
and I usually don't really
care about penis sizes, blah.
But hearing that your small from your
own girlfriend is a whole other story.
Um,
typically,
typically not that guy that gets back at
her by pointing out her physical flaws,
but I don't know where to go from here.
Uh,
it's even more difficult texting with her.
What do I do? Bill? Got Any advice? Okay.
You said you don't know
where to go from here.
I can tell you exactly what to go right
out our front fucking door. That's it.
It's a wrap, sir. It's a wrap. Okay.
Yeah.
Now listen, I'm not saying that she's
wrong for wanting a bigger dick.
Okay?
Like she needs more to satisfy or,
or whatever.
Or She just wants to go out and bang
some fucking big Dick Dude at this point.
All right? You know,
but her tact is wrong.
Okay? You, you, you accepted yourself,
which is one of the greatest things you
can do that leads towards being happy
every day, which leads you to
treating the people around you,
okay?
Respectfully. Which leads them
to treating you respectfully,
which leads to more happiness. She fucked
with the core, your happiness. You know,
you felt good about yourself.
She pointed out something and made
you feel horrible about yourself.
It's one of the worst fucking thing she
could've done as far as mentally to you
and, and, and right now,
the last thing you want to do is go out
and say the same thing to her. All right?
If you really want to do just
paraphrase what the fuck I just said.
It just, just, I dunno and
I would just leave it dead.
I get in the childish thing to do. This
is what you really want to get it back.
Just saying challenges,
thing for me to do would point out some,
some of your physical floss. And the
great thing is is you leave it ambiguous,
okay?
And I guarantee you she's going to be
in a bathroom mirror staring at herself.
Uh,
if you want to get mean,
okay,
but um,
you know what this, but I gotta
tell you some of what's even better.
You got to have this,
what's known as the self esteem breakup,
okay?
Which you totally in the right here
and you just say, listen. All right.
What you said to me,
I thought I used to feel good about
myself and what you said to me,
mess with the core of my own, my own
happiness and how I feel about myself,
and that's not what I'm looking for
in a girlfriend or a potential wife.
And,
uh,
I just can't see you ever being a good
mother if you would say something like
that. It's just something along those
lines. I don't, I don't, I keep going.
Me Don't call me, uh,
whatever the fuck I just said.
I was just trying to paraphrase what the
fuck I said, but it, dude, this, this is,
you should feel good about
yourself. All right? You know, you,
you're not a porn star, but you're
also, you know, you're not like a,
you're not what she's making out to be
here. All right? That's it. You still,
you're still in the game, sir. Okay.
You're not part of the starting five. Hey,
neither am I. You know, but you and
I, we come off that bench. Okay.
We're the kind of guys, well, the
guys that go in the corners, right?
Uh, yeah. Man, that's, that's you're,
you're a hundred percent advice.
My advice would be that this girl is,
is not anywhere near the level
of maturity she needs to be and,
uh, might never even
get to that level. Um,
the point,
the redeeming thing that I can say to her
is she has such a difficult time doing
what she wants to do in life that maybe
she wanted to break up with you for
awhile and she didn't know how
to do it and it was building up.
And then there was just an argument and
then she just said that. Or, um, I dunno.
Have you said anything to her?
I have no idea.
MMM.
Oh, it's funny. He says, uh,
thanks for the weekly podcast.
You have no idea what it means
to me. See, when Amsterdam, well,
from what this other guy was riding,
sir,
there's a bunch of beautiful
ladies out there in Amsterdam,
um, yet who the fuck we're all riding
bikes are in. Great God. Damn. Shake.
Go on. Go get, go, go find yourself
a sweetheart. All right. All right.
There you go. Okay. Bulgaria,
Bulgaria, everybody.
A Billy red face. Um, oh wait a second.
I got to read the last advertising here.
I'm sorry guys. You got a couple here.
We've got a couple, two or three here.
Uh Oh, I got to do the last chunk here.
Last chunk. All right. Where am
I going? Legal Zoom. Everybody.
Most Americans don't have a wealth,
but why? You guys all have stuff,
right? You don't want somebody, you
don't like getting your stuff. Do you?
Legal zoom.com everybody.
You don't want the government
rules dictating what happens
to your property and
minor children. You don't.
So why procrastinate?
Most people say too expensive, too. Time
consuming. I don't want to deal with it,
man. My answers. Legal,
zoom.com too expensive. You're
going to love legal zooms.
Reasonable prices, too. Time consuming.
Most people finish the online process
and just 20 minutes and we're not talking
some fill in the blank forms.
Uh,
your will is state specific and
personalized based on your information.
Best of all,
legal zoom has 12 years of experience
helping people with important legal
matters. Um, it's national make
your will month people. Uh,
so don't wait any longer. Go to legal
zoom.com and get 15% off your last will,
but this offer ends soon or get a living
trust and real receive a pour over will
absolutely free, uh, to
get your special discount.
Be sure to enter Burr in the
referral box at checkout for wills,
powers of attorneys trust and more.
Go to legal zoom.com legal
zoom can provide self help
services at your specific
direction or connect you with an attorney,
but they are not illegal from all right.
stamps.com everybody,
there's nothing instant about getting
postage from the post office driving their
parking. It's a waste of time.
So you use stamps.com instead,
instantly get postage for any letter
or package right from your own desk.
stamps.com is so quick and easy to use
and even a moron like me can use it by
and print official us postage using
your own computer or printer stamps.com
we'll send you a digital scale that
automatically calculates the exact postage
you need. They'll even help you decide
the class of mail based on your needs.
No guesswork.
Plus,
it's convenient to take care of your
mailing and shipping whenever you need to.
24 seven right from your own desk.
You'll never have to go
to the post office again.
I use stamps.com to send out all my DVDs.
I have never repeat,
ever had a problem. Uh, right now use my
last name, birth for the special offer,
no risk trial plus $110 bonus.
That includes a digital scale and
up to $55 free postage. Don't wait.
Go to stamps.com before
you do anything else,
click
on the
microphone@thetopofthehomepagetypeandburburthatstamps.com
enter
burr and finally
Hulu plus everyone.
Uh, I'm sure you've tried
hulu.com. I'm sure you're a fan,
but I want to tell you about the newest,
latest Hulu Hulu Plus Hulu plus lets you
watch thousands of hits shows anytime,
anywhere streaming on your TV or
go to your smartphone or tablet.
Why stand in line or ride a train
and just stare at your feet.
You could be watching your
favorite shows on Hulu.
Plus Hulu plus is a great way to
binge watch your favorite shows.
I'm going to use Hulu plus to catch
up on the old family guy episodes I've
missed when I was on the road or Rockford
files or whatever the hell else I want
to watch, or maybe all the Lord of the
rings. Wouldn't that be phenomenal?
Didn't see an episode,
a new girl that's on Hulu plus two and
if I ever decide to watch lost Hulu plus
is the place for there.
If I ever want to watch 90 hours of lost,
I can do it on Hulu. Plus
you get the point. It's only
seven 99 a month. Everybody,
seven 99 for all the shows and movies
you can watch catch up on current shows.
Been John old and favorite new shows.
It's great.
You can do it all on Hulu plus right now.
You can try Hulu plus for a
couple of weeks for free on me.
When you go to the podcast page at
[inaudible] Dot Com Click on the Hulu plus
banner or go to Hulu plus.com/burr okay.
There you go everybody.
And that right there is all the
advertising for this week. Um, all right,
where am I going here? Back
to the question, Bulgaria.
Everybody ate a Billy red face.
Heard you ask about
Bulgaria in eastern Europe.
I've traveled around Europe over the
last five years in Bulgaria is very nice.
Plus they love Americans.
Serbia is pretty nice too.
They don't love Americans like the bulks,
but uh,
it's still safe even though
we bombed them in the 90s.
They even have a pretty good
sense of humor about it.
And if they know you're American, you're
American. Perfect. Strangers will walk.
Or if they know you're American dish
should be a common common there. Perfect.
Strangers will walk to you and ask and
ask the question, why did you bomb us?
And even they settle, celebrate
a battle they lost to us. Well,
if they came up to me and said, why
did you bomb us? I would be like,
I wasn't even aware of we did that.
What happened?
Uh, that would make it even worse. May
even celebrate a battle. They lost us.
Serbia, Serbia has been very
commercialized over the last 10 years.
And there is a strict code of
masculinity amongst the men,
kind of like Americans plus,
I don't even know what that means.
Plus the exchange rate is great all over
the former Yugoslavia and instead of
booking a hotel,
you can rent a very nice apartment for
a month and it would actually be cheaper
and nicer than a hotel because there's
no first or last or at least as long as
you have cash in a place to crash,
stay away from Romania.
The only good thing I heard about
that country is the country,
which is beautiful in the summer. The
rest of the year it looks like Apalasia
I don't even know what that means. I
don't, I don't even know what that is.
Apple Laka um, I, yeah,
I always feel like if I'm going
to get kidnapped in Europe,
I always feel like it's going to be in
eastern Europe. I would think of that.
And you never hear
anything about Bulgaria,
what the weight and what the fuck
did we do? I need to know this.
We're gonna be dropping
bombs on people in a bad way.
Okay.
We bombed Serbia.
Yeah.
Was that when there are
other Croatia, the Serbians,
Bosnia, Herzegovina. We were all
fucking battling with each other.
That's when you get sloppy and checklists
of archaea became independent of
Russia and now they didn't have a common
enemy and the Russians because they had
pulled out.
You have to like 1990 and
then they instantly picked
up on these wars that have
been gone for like 90 years. Isn't
that what happened? Ah, Jesus.
Hey,
America
bombs Serbia.
Yeah.
NATO bombing of Yugoslavia.
All right.
Reason why I hit USA
America bombing of Serbia.
That's a video. Oh, Bill Clinton.
Oh yeah, I remember that. Oh,
didn't he bomb them?
Because he fucking was fingering in that
fucking refrigerated faced fucking mess
of a woman.
You make me feel like a younger man.
Can I stick this cigar and you pussy.
Um,
the NATO bombing of Yugoslavia was NATO's
military operation against the federal
public of Yugoslavia
during the Kosovo war.
The strikes lasted from March 24th,
1999 to June 10th. My birthday,
1999 the official NATO operation,
well,
code was operation,
allied force, Yada, Yada,
Yada goals,
NATO's objective and the Kosovo conflict
or stated and the North Atlantic
countings means, but yeah, and I imagine
they said it was something about freedom,
but it was really about some sort
of natural resource or power.
MMM.
Strategy today. What the fuck is
it? Come on, let's get to the,
what was her name? Margo Adams.
What was the name of that? Poor.
That unfortunate woman,
you know,
naval civilian. You don't want
to look up Bill Clinton bombs.
You Go Slavia
wait,
Margo Adams was the fucking chicken.
Uh,
what's his face bank from the Red Sox?
The hell was his name. Now he
still is. Wade Boggs. Bill Clinton
bombs.
Yugoslavia.
What the hell was her name?
Was it Margo?
But again with an m the
fuck was the name of like,
why are you stuck that cigar and a thing?
I can't remember her fucking name.
Uh, I'm just going to stick cigar.
Bill Clinton bombs. Yugoslavia cigar.
Let's see if that comes up.
Bill Clinton,
what really happened?
It was bombing killed.
224 people.
Why Clinton bombed the
Serbs. All right, here we go.
Oh, that's just, that's just too long.
You know what? I Dunno why did it,
but Clinton did it. He did it in 1999.
I'll just look at the ground. Yeah,
sorry about that. Sorry. We
uh, sorry. We bombed. Ah,
Jesus Christ. All right, well that's a
podcast for this week. Everybody. I know.
It was kind of all over the
place. Um, as if my life, uh,
this is the wrap ups for the show here.
Now that the show's over,
don't forget to support all the
sponsors or just one of them.
Anything you can support.
Okay. We've got, you know,
you can get your will done at legal zoom.
You get your voice a he voice things.
He voice,
uh,
gives you a toll free number so you
can take business calls from anywhere.
Sound to the office. You remember it. I've
already talked about this stuff. Uh, no.
It shows over. You got Hulu plus
you can binge on all those shows.
If you don't like them, you can check
out Tivo, right. Give you two options.
You know, you don't want to buy
shaved, go to the dollar, shave clubs.
You don't want to buy the blades.
I hate these fucking wrap ups.
You guys heard all of this shit before.
That's it. I'm not doing the wrap ups.
Go Fuck Yourself. I'm all right.
That's the podcast for this week. Okay.
Coming up this week. Why am I shouting?
I am going to be Friday night.
I'm going to be in Boise, Idaho,
Saturday night, Saturday night,
Bozeman, Montana. If both
those shows are not sold out,
they're damn close. Ah, that's, this
is the beginning of the red state tour.
And uh, then right after that,
then I have to do my acting gig.
And I never tell you guys much about the
acting gigs because so many guys I know
get into movies or whatever and then
they tell people they're in them and then
they get cut out or whatever.
So I wait till it's in theaters when
it's in theaters and I'm actually in it.
Then I tell you I'm in the movie. That
seems to be the best way to go about it.
But I always a lot of people out
there where you will go, oh, you know,
you're supposed to be coming to my
fucking flyover state and now you're not.
What's the deal? Well, um, the
shows have not been canceled.
They have been rescheduled.
Okay.
So the first to stay the same,
a Boise state,
July 26 and the Emerson Center for the,
uh,
for the arts theater in Bozeman, Montana
is July 27th. Those are still the same.
El Paso has been moved.
MMM.
I got to change that date on my website,
but right now, uh, Colorado, boulder,
Colorado,
the new date is September the fourth.
September the fifth is the first
day of NFL football. Bup, bup, bup,
Ba. I'm going to try to go to that because
I'm going to be out there in Colorado.
September 6th pikes peak center,
Colorado Springs,
and then, okay. El Paso has
been moved to September 12th.
Yeah.
Okay. We keep going. We
keep going. And then, um,
in November, I don't have the dates up
here on my site yet. In November, they'll,
those are going to be the deadwood.
Uh, Tulsa, Oklahoma, Wichita,
Kansas. Dates will be in November. And uh,
for those of you asking about my,
um,
European tour, these dates are already
on sale. December 5th and Amsterdam,
December 7th in London, December
9th in Dublin, December 11th,
Copenhagen, Denmark,
December 12th, Oslo, Norway.
Uh, December 13th. I'm in
Stockholm, Sweden and rumor has it,
this is confirmed. I'm going to be in
Iceland. That's going to be the last one.
I'm going to be an ric Reykjavik or
Rick Avik over the fuck you say it.
And uh, ah, shit, I just
thought of something else to,
how was I gonna say?
Okay.
You know, I just totally spaced.
I don't fucking know. Anyways,
I'm going to be over there and
other dates coming up or Helsinki.
I'm also going to be in Glasgow,
Scotland.
Okay.
And uh, I think that's it. That'll be it.
Those are all the countries I'm hitting.
I Iceland, Ireland, Scotland, England,
Norway, Sweden, Finland, Copenhagen,
and uh, the Netherlands. So there you
have it. All right, well with any luck,
I'm going to go to Italy. Right before
I do my tour. I'm going to sit there.
Anybody has any advice? Anybody
listen to this podcast over in Italy?
Where should I go? What should
I do? I've got like three days.
I've never been there. Should I go to
Rome first? Should I see the Colosseum?
And if I'm there,
where should I eat?
Because I know everybody out
there is going to be like,
we got the best that day,
but the bubble and they don't, I want
you to tell me where it's at. All right.
That's it. That's the podcast for
this week. Go fuck yourselves. And,
uh, and that's it. I'll talk
to you next week. All right.